the war in Ukraine may have strengthened
Western alliances in Europe but not in
all cases the big outlier is the
Hungarian leader Victor Orban who won't
Supply weapons to Kiev and won't let
them Transit his country my guest from
Budapest is the prime minister's state
Secretary Sultan Kovach do you want
zelenski to win the war we want peace
we don't want him to win whatever it
takes and power is achieved even if any
piece at moscow's price
what whatever happens whatever happens
in Ukraine is no good not only for
Hungary but for Europe so why does
hungary's government think Putin has
made Russia Great again why is Orban so
scared of a mixed race Hungary and what
about those rule of law issues with
Brussels
welcome to conflict Zone thank you for
having me
let's start if we may with the war in
Ukraine as far back as March your prime
minister declared the answer to the
question of which side Hungary is on is
that Hungary is on hungary's side
but that's what the full story is it
you've made a lot of statements and done
a lot of things that will have pleased
your friends in Moscow are you Russia's
Trojan Horse inside NATO
well when you put the question please
also make the quotation proper because
the beginning of that sentence was that
we are going for peace and that is
Hungary was among the first countries to
immediately Coast towards ceasefire and
peace immediate peace talks because
that's the only way actually to try to
sort out that company and indeed uh
whatever anybody else says in this
conflict uh all and each NATO member
State and country regarding the war is
always representing its own interests at
first very obviously we do have joint
Interest being members of the NATO being
members of a defensive Alliance also as
a neighbor of Ukraine should have
started with this very obviously we have
obligations when there's a war raging in
a neighboring country and people are
fleeing for their lives so this is how
we stand and this is how we approach
this company okay I mean I'm not going
to take anything away from the
assistance that you've provided to
Ukrainian refugees which has been
substantial but look at your actions
like refusing point blank to give
Ukraine any weapons or allowing NATO to
transship weapons through Hungary to
help them Moscow must have been
delighted with that no
well we don't know about Moscow and as a
matter of fact we don't care about
Moscow as the Prime Minister and many of
our leading politicians have formulated
uh what really counts for us is that as
a as a as again as a neighboring country
with a substantial 150 000 Hungarian
minority in the neighborhood any weapon
shipment any participation in supplies
would make them as well as Hungary a
Target don't forget about the incident
what happened in Poland we all know that
all neighboring countries of Ukraine can
become by accident or by intent part of
the conflict if they are not careful
enough hungary's position has always
been very clear about weapon shipments
and it stands and that is we are at the
part of we are going for peace if there
was and if there is a conflict an armed
conflict in Central Europe it has always
been bad for hungarians not to talk
about those actually who are middle
meddled in the in this in this War be it
south of Hungary or in this regard
Northeast of Hungary so again this is a
very consistent Hungarian approach to
Armed conflicts in the region it may be
a consistent approach but if you wanted
peace so badly why didn't you tell
Moscow to get its troops out of Ukraine
and do it that way
we did so uh Hungary was among the first
to condemn the aggression and we have
repeatedly have been asking and are
asking for immediate truths withdrawal
and stop of the armed conflict it's a
clear-cut violation of international law
I mean I believe that the prime minister
of foreign minister of parliament as a
matter of fact our president who just
visited Ukraine a couple of days ago
have been completely and fully explicit
about the nature of the war and the
nature of the aggression we see in
Ukraine yes but what you've been
proposing is exactly what Moscow wanted
frees the conflict while the Kremlin had
the upper hand and could cement its
territorial gains in any case why should
Ukraine sit around that so-called peace
talks and surrender territory to a
hostile Invader that's been bombing and
destroying its towns and cities and
murdering its people why should it sit
around with peace talks
and because peace talks send
conversation to each other is the only
way out of the conflict there's another
way out of the conflict which is the
crane
should never have brought in in the
first place
yes but we told you respect and without
speculation but there's only one way if
you wanted to push them out uh and again
instead of escalation and uh this
conflict you know neighboring countries
let me repeat this it's not a new
conflict we see that conflict dating
back to uh 2014 with the unlawful
annexation of the Crimea we've seen
sanction policies uh and attitudes on
behalf of most of the most of us in
Europe the United States and as a matter
of fact NATO not finishing the conflict
as a matter of fact so it was not able
uh the attitude the approach to stop the
conflict it has intensified so again uh
property stocks and effort which we
don't see on behalf of the leaders of
the European Union to step in between
the warring parties come the tension and
try to do something for sorting out the
differences uh that would be the way out
when you say you say that but what kind
of Peace do you think realistically
Moscow would sign with Ukraine while
huge numbers of Russian troops are
occupying vast areas of their country
outnumbered on the battlefield Ukraine
would have had no choice but to
effectively negotiate its own surrender
and you've known that all along
but realistically nobody had nobody
tried uh this is the point here so if
there's a reason for that they don't
want to cement the situation in moscow's
Advantage do they
we believe that uh the bad political
decisions including the sanctioned
policies actually especially on energy
are not are not calming the tension and
are not a way out of the conflict it
rather they rather contribute to the
escalation Hungary has been explicit on
on say the sanction policies and about
uh
I mean hunger is political stance on the
issue as a neighboring country
um we are a small actor uh but we are
a neighbor we are a small actor on this
field very obviously a lot larger forces
a lot larger interests are mingled in
trying to single out Hungary why is it
hungry and Hungarian effort that is not
stopping or not helping to stop the war
would be unjustified without your
respect again hunger is position is very
clear uh don't try to tell us actually
that we are thwarting the war effort we
are thwarting any effort to bring peace
to Ukraine the Hungarian position is
Crystal Clear we are explicit we are not
hiding we are not having second thoughts
we would like to see this happening
actually on behalf of those who are
triggering the tension rather than
calming it why do you consistently play
Down suggestions of close relations
between Vladimir Putin and your prime
minister you've said in the past the
close political ties attributed to the
PM and the Russian president don't exist
the Russian the relations are not closer
than those between Russia and Germany
that's not quite true is it
well there's a very simple reason
because nothing substantiates what you
are trying to tell
hungary's ties connections relationship
with Russia is no more intensive or
particular in its uh quality than say it
was or it's the case if it's about
Germany uh 12 meetings in 13 years
between their leaders 12 meetings even
even Victor Orban said when he was in
Moscow February the 1st three weeks
before Russia invaded this is our 12th
meeting that's rather rare he was crying
about it it is unusual have you counted
the meetings conversations and
negotiations with German French Italian
and other leaders you know you don't uh
the the reason is actually that when you
have
let's put it that way in many respect a
strategic partnership with a country
with supplying you raw materials with a
special regard to our energy resources
gas and oil which is a historical
inheritance so it's not the fault not
the uh not the activity of this
government which has uh uh resulted in
uh almost one-sided dependence for
historical reasons on Russian energy you
have to have a proper relationship which
is trying to make things uh countable
and accountable and the special
relationship may be uh formulated as you
suggested only from this perspective but
when you are dependent on Russian gas by
uh 65 oil more than 80 percent I believe
this kind of cautiousness is required so
so this is your priority isn't it then
this is your priority don't on any
account endanger your energy supplies
from Russia that's your priority in this
conflict isn't it don't try to suggest
that anybody else is having a moral
superiority or a moral uh approach not
just trying to clarify what yours is I'm
just trying to clarify what your
priority is the best interest of Hungary
and that is the Hungarian people to have
an accountable relationship with those
countries actually we are in connection
uh our partners in trade energy supplies
uh this is a very same Hungarian
attitude when we are members of the NATO
let's put it that way which is based on
mutual respect uh and when a country uh
country's economy and that is very
existence including the households uh um
when it's about energy is dependent on
the resources that are coming from
Russia you have to be very careful
because any step to a wrong direction
would basically mean the whole of the
country immediately
you
um
had uh Mr Orban in Moscow as I said
February the first three weeks before
Russia invaded
um this was a peace Mission he described
it as a peace Mission why do you think
it failed so spectacularly
well if it was a failure
three weeks later
have also failed so again Hungary knows
its place in international relations as
I just mentioned to you we know that we
are especially by military or security
perspectives we are a small country uh
and our room for maneuver uh our
political
um
tools at our hands are very limited but
I just explained to you actually that
when we have to rely on very
unfortunately because of the uh Missing
infrastructural Investments on behalf of
Western European countries in the
European Union on the one side is uh
supply of energy then you have to be
respectful of what is happening and
again the prime minister with a very
deep historical knowledge and the 30
years political experience is exactly in
possession of the knowledge how to
handle situations like this we don't
have more say we don't have more
influence on a great power like Russia
uh than uh say uh Germany or France so
when we try to talk about peace very
obviously it was not the Hungarian
perspectives and
suggestions and insights that were
making any
decisive uh influence on what Russia has
decided to do
just um four years after Putin seized
Crimea which you spoke about a little
earlier and fueled the war in the
donbass region Victor Orban heaped
Praise on the Russian leader saying in
2018 it needs to be recognized that
Putin has made his country great again
and that Russia is once again a player
on the world stage what's so great about
a country that launches illegal Invasion
cracks down increasingly on human rights
and murders its political opponents at
home and abroad what's what's greatness
about that
well with all you respect the sentence
the words of the Prime Minister Asics
are exactly true this is what we see
today Russia regained uh strength
um claiming to regaining uh influence
and has started the war we do know that
it was an aggression we do know that it
was an undue and um and the conflict
that could have been prevented actually
implant recognition is there with
Western European leaders so who could
have prevented who could have prevented
this conflict who could have prevented
this conflict
I'm suggesting that those Powers
actually who can be perhaps to say
measured to the powers and the influence
of Russia but with all due respect the
sentence of the Prime Minister is
exactly true this is what we see
this is greatness is it murder and
repression at home don't bother you at
all that's that's also a sign of
greatness is it well you and you can
have an opinion and as well as we have
an opinion of what is happening and how
what quality what we think about it but
still it doesn't change is the fact
actually that what what the Prime
Minister was referring to is happening
right now
Mr Kovach why is it that since the War
Began your government seems to have gone
out of its way to do favors for the
Kremlin why did you insist that the
Russian Orthodox patriarch kiril be
removed from an EU sanctions list
despite his active promotion and support
for the war
well if it's about the sanction policies
especially when it's about uh
individuals related to churches it's a
matter of principle the Hungarian
government has always been clear about
the sanctioned policies
inappropriateness actually if it's about
political not to talk about military
goals uh right from uh dating back from
2014 and here we go uh in 2012 uh 22
there is a war after years of sanction
policies it's about uh the churches and
church personnel we we believe it's
dividing line so if you start uh
introducing sanctions on uh church
leaders where are you going to stop who
is going to make the difference what
about Russian diplomats then you you if
you wanted to sanction individuals there
are other approaches and other
possibilities to reach the desired
Target not through and wire uh their
religious uh position or sanctioning
churches as it was suggested back then
you did have other possibilities you
could have targeted Russian diplomats in
protests that moscow's aggression unlike
other EU countries who kicked out some
400 of them what stopped you doing the
same were you scared of moscow's
reaction
where we are exactly doing what others
are doing you exactly know how it's
going actually behind the scenes if you
like there's always a big debate uh lots
of um I'm sorry to say bargaining to put
on that list and who not to put on the
place uh to be crystal clear here uh and
again we have before uh the suggestion
and don't blame us on something that we
have indicated uh beforehand we have
indicated that for principle uh for
matters of principle we are not
supporting any sanction on any religious
personnel well then I wasn't talking
about religious person I was talking
about diplomats
yeah but if it's about did you throw any
of the diplomats out there's no complete
there's no complete ban of diplomats
either so you have to be very careful
how you
um how you impose how you implement
essential policies because uh the
ability and capability to maintain
conversation with the the opposition
side and that is blame for the war and
we all know that have committed
aggression is equally important so uh
when it's about imposing sanctions and
bringing in new sanctions uh you have to
always have to be very careful both from
this perspective I mean diplomatic and
if you like Power perspective but also
economically as I just suggested earlier
you you have been very careful you've
also had four months to ratify Sweden
and finland's accession to Nato despite
saying you'll do it you still haven't
you've said you'll do it now early next
year
um so why the hold up
just to be difficult
well just to tell you one example
actually which is uh basically
overburdening the Hungarian Parliament
is our conversational European
commission and the European institutions
so we have accepted and we have
negotiated 17 different measures and
points by which they start started and
tried to standardize uh the problems
actually we have in our relationship we
were ready to sort them out they require
time and I got to tell you as the Prime
Minister pointed out not a minute is
going to be lost because of Hungary
in October I mean you say that in
October MPS from your party blocked a
motion that would have speeded up the
process of ratifying Sweden and
finland's accession why did they do that
you respect we are the Hungarian
government the Hungarian Parliament has
its own agenda it's going to be put on
its uh
um uh timeline and Julie accepted as we
suggested because the Hungarian
government is fully supportive of those
two candidates so with all due respect
don't try to tell us and give us
timelines and urge us into decisions
which are going to be made according to
our own timeline Mr Kovach Hungary has
been at odds with Brussels for some
years over rule of law issues among them
what they see as your excessive control
of the media and your lacks attitude to
corruption surrounding the disbursement
of EU funds you say you have addressed
those concerns the EU is about to decide
whether you've done enough you certainly
waited a long time to do anything at all
didn't you nobody ever was able will be
able to Define what exactly the rule of
law means there are no
um how to say unbiased and objective
factor and the benchmark by which it can
be measured
we have I believe plaid and clearly
indicated that we are ready to engage in
the conversation with the commission if
it's about particular issues it took the
commission almost two years actually to
tell us to tell us what exactly their
problem is we have sorted those 17
points I've already already referred to
out uh these were technical issues from
the Hungarian perspective not matters of
principle so on our behalf there is no
obstacle to uh accept or sign the two
agreements that are required actually to
have accept have access to the uh to the
funds and with all due respect it's not
going to be dependent on hungry our
expectations are that as we have
negotiated and we made compromise and
very clearly uh doing everything at
hunger's disposal to fulfill the
requests on behalf of the commission we
are expecting uh signatures and we are
expecting that money to arrive to
Hungary duly as it should be arriving
um uh by now as a matter of fact let us
remind the viewers that the rff has been
accepted two years ago the original
intent was to have access
considerable amounts of money that would
help economists recover after the
pandemics and that is the coronavirus
the the covet crisis two years lost uh
we still haven't received one eurocent
other countries are enjoying it it's not
a matter of uh Rule and law uh rule of
law and uh you know human rights and
other issues you were mentioning but
it's a matter of competitiveness and
equal treatment in the European Union
it's it's not just me mentioning human
rights attitude a lot of your government
policies have been condemned pretty much
unanimously by not just by human rights
groups but the UN Human Rights office
the organization for security and
cooperation in Europe the Council of
Europe the U.S state department but you
see all that as some kind of what
liberal woke anti-white conspiracy
against Hungary you really believe in
all that these organizations governments
uh and the political parties and
political Lobby groups exactly know that
there are no problems with human rights
here in Hungary
in July Victor Orban railed against what
he called an ideological trick of the
internationalists left to say Europe's
population is already mixed race we
hungarians are not a mixed race and we
don't want to become a mixed race mixed
politicians in the post-west aren't
Nations anymore but a conglomerate of
people what are you so afraid of in
Hungary diluting your racial purity
congoose perspective on those issues you
just mentioned is very clear for the
past more than decade by now Hungary had
chosen a different way when it's about
uh dealing with the ending uh population
uh uh issues uh we have introduced new
family policies based on the traditional
family in face of the developments uh
invest in Europe and the United States
we have chosen a different economic path
based on jobs and the uh
um employment of hungarians as many as
possible we have created one million new
jobs we've been very clear about if it's
about the Hungarian Youth and protecting
children's right that they belong to the
parents under the age of 18 so there's
no place for any kind of lmbtq
propaganda in uh I understand that I
understand that but Mr Mr orban's
comments were widely condemned as racist
the U.S Envoy against anti-Semitism
Deborah lipstadt said she was deeply
alarmed by the rhetoric that clearly
evokes Nazi racial ideology she's right
isn't he I mean what all bands there was
nothing a dog whistle to the far right
wasn't it it really sounds like the
so-called illiberal uh persecution that
you and many Western European media
started against Hungary years ago you
exactly know that in central European
vocabulary
what the Prime Minister said what it
means it it clearly means that Hungary
has never been a multi-ethnic society or
uh country by the standards of Western
Europe it has always been multi-ethnic
by the standards of Europe's own history
and that is central European history so
you don't have to tell us what
multi-ethnic environment means here in
Hungary where we have 11 National
minorities living together for uh
centuries or rather A Thousand Years
dating back so
everybody exactly knows what the Prime
Minister means by those uh those words
and we are not standing alone most of
central European Central European people
uh think alike and that is uh we don't
want to be a new a new a new perception
of multi-ethnicity bring into into
Central Europe we see in France Germany
and in the UK just briefly back to the
war NATO once
to win the war your prime minister calls
him an opponent NATO sends more and more
weapons you say that's just prolonging
the war do you want zelenski to win the
war
we want peace
we don't want him to win whatever he
takes and how it's achieved even if it's
a piece of moscow's price
what whatever happens whatever happens
in Ukraine is no good not only for
Hungary but for Europe you see what is
happening you see the looming inflation
and economic crisis uh as a matter of
fact this is this is a crisis which is a
result of bad political decisions rather
than reality and that is the lack of raw
materials and the proper economic crisis
well uh it's it's all it all goes back
it all goes back to the origins the
ongoing and the future of this war
according to the Western European heads
of states and Western European mindset
we here in Central Europe especially as
a neighbor of Ukraine have chosen a
different path and that is we are
calling immediate truths peace talks and
uh stop of the fighting uh because
that's the only way out of the conflict
I I understand that but as a NATO member
you cannot bring yourself to say you
want Ukraine to win Russia was the
aggressor you've you've acknowledged
that but you can't say that you want
Ukraine to win
now with all you respect NATO is a
defensive Alliance and NATO is not
having uh anything to do without a
common decision in in Ukraine so what
you see on behalf of the member state is
a different matter we are fully and
completely standing together with our
nature allies and we have always
followed and are going to follow the
common NATO decisions
been good to have you on conflict Zone
thank you very much indeed thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]